well it is a very tough time for  representative susie lee this holiday  she traveled to ohio this week after her  ill mother started receiving in-home  hospice care  her mother passed away last night after  an illness and tonight  in an unrelated coincidence the  representative has tested positive for  the virus  in a statement she said i am currently  asymptomatic and plan to participate in  remote memorial services for my mother  over the weekend  and starting next week i will continue  my congressional work remotely  while isolating until i know it is safe  to exit  isolation our thoughts are certainly  with representative lee and her family  tonight